almost five days on from the deadliest
earthquake to hit turkey and Syria in
decades millions of people have been
left to sift through the rubble and
Salvage what is left of their lives Sky
News has been there since the start of
the week and witnessed moments of
desperation and despair but we also
filmed moments of relief as people were
rescued from the rubble a warning the
following documentary features images of
people who have died this is disaster
Zone the turkey Syria earthquake
[Music]
building after building
disintegrating
in the aftermath of one of the deadliest
earthquakes in turkey's history
measuring 7.8 in magnitude and 18
kilometers in depth
this earthquake was shallow
powerful the worst possible combination
and it struck at 17 minutes past four in
the morning as many slept in their beds
the moment that changed so many millions
of lives captured here on CCTV
[Applause]
what came next was almost Beyond
imagination
foreign
[Music]
their world had been transformed into
the most horrific landscape
what's up multiple story buildings
flattened
whole streets destroyed within seconds
the southern Turkish city of gazientep
was this earthquake's epicenter
but its shock waves caused destruction
across Southern turkey and neighboring
Syria
search and rescue teams began the near
impossible locating those trapped under
the rubble
quickly relentlessly the death toll Rose
from hundreds to thousands to tens of
thousands
and then just nine hours after the first
a second shallow quake
measuring 7.5 magnitude
it's Tremors felt across the Middle East
for The Rescuers it was just what they
didn't need around 45 minutes ago there
was an Aftershock of uh you know more
than six points magnitude and he did
cause a certain extra damage not just
only hampering the rescue airports
because I did see on my way this is my
second visit here some of the buildings
that were uh that looked fine before
were also damaged
this is the second biggest earthquake in
the last century has also government
official said I have I myself a little
bit with my family it was around four
o'clock uh all of a sudden uh quiet
night became a chaos the epicenter of
Monday morning's Quake was here in the
southern Turkish city of gaziente it
lasted around a hundred seconds and
traveled about 400 kilometers in that
time wreaking havoc across Southern
turkey and Northern Syria
the second massive shallow Quake struck
nine hours later just 60 kilometers
north of the first in the district of
Caravan marash causing further
Devastation to an already fragile region
[Music]
no stranger to earthquakes turkey is
relatively well equipped to deal with
the Fallout from disasters
but in neighboring Syria where there's
already a decade-long humanitarian
crisis it's a very different story
[Music]
displaced people already vulnerable from
fleeing Civil War were living in the
exact region worst hit
but earthquakes don't recognize borders
and responders were faced with the
hugely complex job of navigating this
human tragedy on multiple levels
[Music]
too
many the Syrian white helmets are a
group of Civilian volunteers better
known for their wartime rescue efforts
in rebel-held areas in the north of the
country
but with external Aid unable to reach
Syria they were the only Emergency
Response Team on the ground
all right
yeah one of their many remarkable
rescues
[Music]
pulled from underneath the rubble where
she'd been for more than 24 hours
thank God you're safe her rescuer says
as her desperate father stands by ready
to take her into his arms
[Music]
war and earthquakes one trauma following
another leaving a population in despair
the scale of the damage is quite
important it's enormous this is a region
that has been already suffering from a
difficult situation with very weak
infrastructure in hospitals and so on we
have a situation where people themselves
are vulnerable with 15 million already
living in difficult situations here and
beyond that now comes this earthquake
that is compounding the suffering of the
people
those hospitals that survived the Quake
were completely overwhelmed
Northern Syria's medical infrastructure
has been crippled by years of heavy
airstrikes
doctors already struggling for resources
or equipment left unable to cope with
the severity and the sheer scale of the
injuries endured by the survivors
alhamdulillah
foreign
with hospitals full doctors have to make
life or death decisions at the door
the earthquake we started to receive
many cases hundreds of casualties so far
the number is about 100 the martyrs is
about 30 we know and we have information
that hundreds of patients are still
under the place
uh the situation is too bad we need
urgent help
Ed the chaos often came the call for
silence as rescue teams listen intently
for voices
hoping for the tiniest of sounds from
underneath the rubble
and excruciating and often never-ending
weight
the rescue and Aid response was more
coordinated in the urban areas of
Southern turkey but in remote
mountainous Villages and Rural border
towns they're still waiting for outside
help
as my team and I traveled into the
disaster Zone we soon came across Ahmet
yilmas at one of the only functioning
airports
foreign
here from his home in South Wales he was
desperately trying to reach the Mountain
Village he grew up in that's the house
that's the house yeah I mean it's
completely collapsed he showed me photos
of his brother Ali's house he tells me
Ali is dead and his wife is seriously
injured two of their children his nieces
are missing
we decide to travel with Ahmet or at
least get as close as we could to his
village on our way he got a call from
his niece to say that nobody was coming
to help them
over to you
[Music]
as we climbed up into the mountains it
was easy to see why help might be
hampered these remote communities stood
little chance
[Applause]
[Music]
Ahmet reunited with his sister fatter
faced with the unimaginable task of
looking for his missing nieces
I never seen this happen before my left
never and also
there is brothers and daughters
so your two nieces are stupid
they're missing yes
and has there been any other help from
outside no nobody has signed it outside
but there's no police here there's no
military here
nobody houses you see how many days the
Earth cook happens you know three days
or four days nobody comes
from the from the council by Evans
government doing police or Army latings
hatai in turkey's far south eastern
corner
was one of the worst hit areas of this
devastating earthquake
[Music]
its location on the Syrian border means
it's become home to hundreds of
thousands of Syrian refugees fleeing War
it was a place struggling to cope before
the ground beneath it shook
[Music]
with no signs of professional help
people used whatever tools they could
get their hands on picking through the
debris desperately trying to save those
trapped inside
we have no electricity we have any
addition machines to supply our machines
we have no support yet from the
government
we have now Four Towers no one cup yeah
nobody nobody are you here to touch this
understand from the 40 hour yes I am the
one waiting here from 40 hours no one
can is came an area here to touch now we
are dying here no it's dying okay just
dying
this boy was pulled out
Rescuers took him from his mother's arms
to resuscitate him
they tried and tried but they couldn't
bring him back to life
but there are glimmers of Hope amid the
bleakness
this baby was carried out from a crushed
building alive followed by its mother
she's weak and traumatized but she and
her baby are both alive together they
survived more than 24 hours after their
home collapsed around them
there are questions over how prepared
they were here for a natural disaster
long predicted to happen
but these Rescuers just focused on the
job in front of them and every person
they held down to safety spurred them
off
as time passes there's less and less
likelihood of finding people alive
[Music]
cruel winter weather only shortens the
window of Hope
the snow hampers Aid reaching more rural
areas
the Sub-Zero temperatures are punishing
for the homeless survivors
no wonder that warm clothes are photos
[Music]
foreign
Nepal and Haiti but these are mainly
poor countries where you don't expect a
proper response but this is turkey a
relatively rich country but it is just
the scale of the of the tragedy here
that is overwhelmed the authorities and
as for as for over the Border in Syria
well the question there is really does
the government even care about the
people in those Northern areas that it
doesn't control
[Music]
in many areas of Syria they are still
trying to scrape away at the piles of
rubble looking for survivors
no easy task in a place already
devastated by more than a decade of War
but moments like this one make it all
worthwhile
a newborn baby still tied by umbilical
cord to her dead mother was saved
she is a miracle orphan her skin Roar
from the cold and bruised from the Crush
she is recovering in an incubator in
hospital
her tragedy is the story of countless
other children in a disaster which
continues to get worse
about 70 of the patient I were refusing
are children this is horrific you can
imagine that our healthless
infrastructure here is already collapsed
after the 12 years of war there's severe
funding costs we were already struggling
before this crisis hit us right now our
hospitals are not coping our doctors are
totally overwhelmed we've been working
flat out without sleep since the
earthquake I mean it's just it's just
disastrous
foreign
will keep going but the devastation that
sweeps as far as the eye can see is a
constant reminder of how much the teams
on the ground have left to do
back over the Border in the Turkish city
of Caravan Mirage
[Music]
and has been rescued after being trapped
for 48 hours
but he's not relieved he's distraught
says
foreign
[Music]
the rescue operation is improving every
day but it's too late for so many who
survived the earthquake itself but not
the hours and the days afterwards
president erdogan made a plea for
international help soon after and it has
started to arrive
[Music]
Qatar a close Ally of turkeys is one of
the 45 countries that has sent Aid and
Manpower
Britain is another Redwater gonna move
out first gives us a couple of minutes
Head Start we'll get clear we'll go
straight to our sector and work from
there keep Communications keep together
as a team a team of 77 firefighters have
got to work in hatai
come on
they've brought specialist equipment
sniffer dogs and hope there's always
hope and there's lots of evidence to
suggest people in the right conditions
survive for quite some time so yeah
that's all we're here for the British
search and rescue team have seismic
listening devices and concrete braking
equipment
so if there are people still alive in
some of the voids inside the wreckage
they stand a chance of reaching them
lots of information
about
avoids the likelihood of people in there
but an indication from the dog like all
we're going to do is recording all that
information now and then deciding let's
send a team here they should be this one
is it is quite dangerous it was going to
take a long time to dig in and find out
there's no clear precise indications
that there's someone live in there at
the moment so that's still what we're
searching for so we're still looking
I've been in the Turkish city of nurda
where workers are making frantic rescue
attempts
the girl is calling urgently for their
help
I've heard my sister crying in the
rubble she says please be quick please
her grandfather is being ushered away
from a scene he can't bear to leave
foreign
[Music]
with the ambulance on its way the search
team listened for signs of life
[Music]
since yesterday night he tells me we
will find her we will find her and with
that the sister of the missing girl
passes out
everything
more than three days on and it is the
Frantic nature of the search now and the
humanity of it all people willing The
Rescuers to succeed here but often it's
desperate hope followed by the depths of
grief
they didn't hear another voice but that
doesn't stop them waiting
as we left Hope was fading here the girl
who fainted was back she will not give
up
an hour away from nerda in gazientep I
get the opportunity to speak to one of
the heroic rescue workers Samar has been
helping find people since the Quake hit
it's so so hard for me because I'm from
and they are my family and my friends
are living in them in here and and
searching and finding someone
it's so hard for me because emotionally
although physically is the conditions
are so difficult especially the weather
is too cold it's really so hard I'm
social worker sometimes I'm crying
sometimes I'm laughing and I I try to
feel my better
and I try to see the people yes this is
just a number because if the if the
field M40 I can't I can't work the hair
I'm not okay but I have to be okay
[Music]
the coming months and years the towns
and cities of this region will be
rebuilt in many cases they may well be
improved to better withstand future
earthquakes as for the people
well they will not recover so easily
their lives torn apart by the scale of
the loss here will for many
be defined by this tragedy
[Music]
the turkey Syria earthquake of winter
2023 will be remembered for Generations
[Music]
mark down as one of the darkest days in
its history